alors bonjour à tous donc il ya quelques
années j'étais ici à lyne st en effet
l'année dernière je suis parti en
birmanie vous le connaissez peut-être ce
pays aussi sous le nom de meilleures
marges alors je suis parti en birmanie
et je vais vous raconter l'histoire
d'une rencontre
alors pour vous mettre dans le contexte
la birmanie ça un pays d'asie sud-est
qui s'est ouvert il ya peu j'étais à la
capitale culturelle
liang hoon j'ai passé plusieurs journées
et dès qu'on sent de la ville on voit
qu'il ya énormément de chant deschamps
qui sont plutôt sec et surtout quand ce
n'est pas la peur des moussons vraiment
envoyer la terre très asséché alors pour
ça vous avez des fermiers qui ont porté
des normes arrosoir pour pouvoir arroser
ces terres ont donc des allers retours
entre le puy et les champs pour pouvoir
arroser ses terres imaginez qu'en
l'espace d'une journée ils portent de 6
à 10 tonnes d'eau soit plus d'une
centaine d'aller-retour dans la journée
donc vous comprenez bien cette technique
est plutôt lente et surtout inefficace
et c'est là justement j'ai rencontré
débit des bing dean alors début on dîne
c'est la co fondatrice d'une entreprise
sociale est en fait débit elle avait un
seul objectif c'était aider les fermiers
birman et en 2004 son entreprise a créé
la réderie nos alors la reine rhino
c'est une pompe qu'on utilise avec les
jambes
c'est un peu comme les thés peur qu'il y
avait dans les années 80 est en fait
grâce à ce type de pompe en 20 minutes
ont fait l'équivalent de deux heures de
travail avec la méthode traditionnelle
donc c'est sympa vous balader dans les
champs et vous voyez des fermiers en
train de faire leur gym du matin et qui
permettent un
si de pouvoir envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école parce qu'ils n'ont plus besoin
de travailler dans les champs
alors du coup c'est un produit qui est
ludique un produit qui est efficace et
surtout un produit qui est accessible à
la plupart des fermiers bien ans c'est
un bel exemple de ce que j'appelle de
l'ingénierie positive alors je m'appelle
isabelle lui et depuis deux ans je vais
à la rencontre d'hommes et de femmes qui
utilisent la technologie pour améliorer
la vie des autres ça va être des
ingénieurs comme daniel salamanque un
qui va utiliser des drones pour envoyer
des médicaments dans les zones reculées
de colombie ou alors des entrepreneurs
comme konm i am qui a développé une
brique facilement emboîtables qui
utilisent le sol des rizières et qui
permet d'avoir une brique qui est
environnemental et surtout qui permet de
rendre le logement accessible au plus
grand nombre
c'est donc des acteurs du changement qui
ont décidé de faire de l'ingénierie
positive alors avant de parler
d'ingénierie positive on va parler
d'ingénierie l'ingénierie si on regarde
la définition c'est la conception et la
réalisation d'un projet industriel
en d'autres termes c'est notre capacité
de transformer de la matière pour lui
donner une fonction
cette fonction ça peut être soit des
pompes à pédales soit envoyé des
voitures en orbite
alors comme on n'a pas forcément tous
envie d'envoyer des voitures en orbite
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire d'autre
alors c'est pour ça maintenant que j'ai
envie de vous parler d'ingénierie
positif et pourquoi j'en suis venu là
parce que moi même je suis ingénieur
mécanique et j'ai passé plusieurs années
dans l'industrie et dans ces années j'ai
pu faire trois constats le premier c'est
que nos entreprises sont en quête
d'innovation
s'il ya une chose qui est constant dans
le monde et que le monde est en
changement
il est un changement et surtout ils
changent de plus en plus vite
par exemple les nouvelles technologies
alors je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant on est déjà dans la quatrième
révolution industrielle
on était en train de s'adapter à la
troisième qui était avec
l'automatisation internet et maintenant
on va parler de data va parler de
machine learning parler d'intelligence
artificielle plein de nouveaux
changements auxquels les entreprises
font en sorte de s'adapter pour pouvoir
les maîtriser et du coup innovation est
un peu devenu synonyme de maîtriser les
dernières inventions techniques mais
l'innovation c'est pas ça l'innovation
c'est aussi s'est trouvé une solution
pour répondre à un besoin et nos besoins
changent aussi
par exemple il ya dix ans nous étions 6
8 5 milliards d'habitants sur cette
planète
aujourd'hui nous sommes 7 5 milliards
d'habitants en dix ans près de 1
milliard d'habitants en plus vous
imaginez bien cela change nos besoins
cela change nos modes de consommation et
ça c'est un des changements parmi les
nombreux changements qui lie
actuellement
donc voilà premier constat les
entreprises changent pour s'adapter aux
besoins de notre monde qui change très
rapidement
le deuxième point c'est que les employés
quittent les entreprises avant surtout
quand on est un ingénieur on rentrait
dans un grand groupe et on y rester pour
toute sa carrière
aujourd'hui les employés sont plus
mobiles et surtout les employés sont en
quête de sens générations cobayes un
fait une enquête l'année dernière qui
montrait que 79% des 18-35 ans voulait
un emploi qu'ils soient alignés avec
leurs valeurs et que pour eux c'était
primordial donc des jeunes qui
n'hésitent plus à sortir du cadre à ne
plus être cadre mais pas que des jeunes
même des personnes plus âgées je
rencontre et je reçois des messages
d'ingénieurs qui en 40 50 60 ans des
personnes souvent haut placé qui ont des
postes à responsabilité et pourtant se
disent qu'ils ont envie de changer de
métier se disent qu'ils sont en quête de
sens et je parlais avec un directeur
dans le bâtiment qui me disait le
problème c'est que ce ne sont pas les
mauvais qui partent au contraire c'est
des gens qui ont un regard critique des
gens qui sont passionnés des personnes
qui sont entières alors comment est ce
qu'on fait pour retenir ses talents
comment est ce qu'on fait pour mobiliser
leur énergie
après le troisième point c'est que nous
sommes face à des urgences sociales et
environnementales alors que maintenant
avec internet on ne peut plus dire on ne
savait pas on voit l'apparition des
consom'acteurs les consom'acteurs c'est
des consommateurs qui ont décidé d'être
acteurs de leur consommation et de
n'acheter des produits qu'à des
entreprises qu'ils considèrent éthique
eidelman a sorti une étude qui montrait
que 80% des personnes pensent qu'une
entreprise peut lier intérêts
économiques et un impact positif pour la
société alors on parle des consommateurs
mais même les investisseurs sont en
train de changer
je sais pas si vous connaissez blackrock
blackrock
c'est le plus gros fonds
d'investissement mondial ils ont des
parts significatives dans près de 18
entreprises du cac-40 français et le
mois dernier larry fink le pdg de
blackrock envoyé une lettre à toutes les
entreprises dont blackrock est
actionnaire cette lettre les encourager
à oeuvrer pour le bien commun
pourquoi parce que de façon très
pragmatique
larry fink pense qu'une entreprise ne
peut pas être pérenne ne peut pas être
durable si elles ne montrent pas qu'elle
a un impact positif
pour la société on rentre donc dans une
nouvelle ère où les entreprises devront
être responsable elles vont devoir
inclure la responsabilité dans leur
stratégie dans leur vision dans leurs
objectifs
alors voici mon bilan de l'industrie des
entreprises qui sont en quête
d'innovation des entreprises qui ont du
mal à retenir leurs talents et des
entreprises qui doivent devenir
responsable alors si au lieu de prendre
ses problèmes ses contraintes
un par un on se disait qu'il y avait une
solution globale à ses trois contraintes
si on essayait de repenser notre façon
de faire de l'industrie
einstein l'avait bien compris il disait
on ne peut pas résoudre un problème avec
le même type de penser que ce qui l'a
engendré alors repensons l'industrie et
moi je vous propose cette idée l'idée
d'ingénierie positive c'est-à-dire de
concentrer sur la conception de produits
qui améliorent la vie des personnes
et pourquoi est ce que l'ingénieur est
positif ça change notre façon de voir
l'industrie parce que l'ingénierie
positif ça repose sur trois piliers le
premier la rentabilité économique
le deuxième l'épanouissement des
employés et le troisième la résolution
d'enjeux sociaux et environnementaux et
en fait c'est la synergie de ces trois
piliers qui va créer de l'ingénierie
positive si vous fait travailler des
personnes sans projet qui a du sens ce
qui améliore la société vous aurez des
personnes qui sont motivés et des
personnes qui vont donner toute leur
énergie pour créer de nouveaux produits
pour innover ils vont innover quoi les
produits qui vont résoudre des besoins
en termes de survie en termes de
sécurité donc de produits que vont se
vendre en gros l'ingénierie positif
c'est cette opportunité de rentrer dans
ce cercle vertueux et je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut forcément
mettre la technologie au coeur de notre
société
je dis qu'il faut faire preuve de coeur
pour remettre l'humain et la planète au
centre de la technologie et ça c'est
vraiment une nouvelle façon un peu
d'aborder l'industrie d'aborder
l'ingénierie et si vous pensez que c'est
peut-être impossible de faire de
l'ingénieur est positive alors je vous
renvoie un peu à votre jeunesse à votre
âme d'enfant et ici je vous avais parlé
de ça à l'époque
vous aurez pas un dit que c'était
impossible
vous nous auriez trouvé sa logique même
vous seriez demander pourquoi est ce
qu'on fera autrement et j'ai pu faire
une étude durant durant le temps où g
j'explorais l'ingénierie positif c'est
que 100 personnes
cent pour cent des personnes qui
réussissent à faire de l'ingénierie
positives sont des personnes qui ont
essayé par exemple si on prend un débit
débit au début elle ne s'est pas dit je
vais créer la pompe la plus efficace au
monde ce qu'elle s'est dit c'est comment
faire pour aider les fermiers pour
qu'ils passent moins de temps dans les
champs et que leurs enfants puissent
aller à l'école et ne pas travailler
quand daniel a démarré son entreprise ne
va pas chercher à faire des drones qui
pouvait atteindre des hautes collines
colombienne il s'est demandé comment
faire avec mon savoir-faire en
aéronautique pour rendre accessible la
santé à plus de monde et cancon ni à
développer ces nouvelles briques ne
s'est pas dit que ça allait
révolutionner l'industrie de la brique
au cambodge
il s'est dit de quelle façon on peut
créer un produit qui pourrait permettre
que tous les cambodgiens est un toit et
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui m'avait dit
l'innovation ça commence par le choeur
et ensuite le cerveau suis alors on est
bien loin des process industriels
vous imaginez ça serait étape 1 écoutez
votre coeur
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas plus
d'ingénierie positive dans l'industrie
et surtout comment faire pour qu'on en
ait plus alors tout d'abord je pense
qu'il faut se mettre à inspirer les
personnes leur montrer des exemples de
projets le dinh qui marche leur montrer
que c'est possible de faire de
l'ingénierie positive je me souviens il
ya quelques années on était avec des
amis ingénieurs en vacances on regarde
un documentaire qui parle d énergie
carbone pendant deux heures le
documentaire pointe du doigt l'industrie
explique notre consommation déraisonnée
des énergies carbone et en gros nous
montre comment va droit dans le mur
et c'est vrai qu'à la fin du
documentaire je me souviens on était
tous un peu en position foetale et on
avait envie d'attendre la fin du monde
donc je pense que c'est bien de parler
des problèmes il faut parler du problème
par contre il faut aussi montrer des
solutions des exemples qui fonctionne
qui marche
que ce soit dans les médias dans l'école
les entreprises pourquoi est ce qu'on
parle tout le temps d'un steve jobs et
qu'on parle pas d'une débit d'un daniel
ou d'un combi des personnes tout aussi
inspirante les personnes tout aussi
ingénieuse alors voilà déjà commencé par
inspirer les personnes parce que plus de
personnes sont inspirés au plus de
vocations sont ancrées une fois qu'on a
inspiré ces personnes pour leur donner
l'envié de faire de l'ingénierie positif
il faut les former à faire de
l'ingénierie positif alors souvent un
déblocage pour faire de l'ingénierie
positif c'est de se dire j'ai pas créer
j'ai pas l'idée d'une innovation
technologique qui pourrait changer le
monde
alors je vais vous rassurer tout de
suite
la technique c'est seulement une petite
partie d'un projet le reste c'est
vraiment comprendre le besoin comprendre
ses utilisateurs essayez d'être en
proximité avec la société et c'est
vraiment ça qui va faire la réussite
d'un projet d'ingénierie positive c'est
plus vos compétences humaines votre
savoir être qui va primer sur votre
technologie et puis après certains
pensent que faire de l'ingénierie
positif
c'est simple et c'est une histoire de
bonne volonté ce n'est pas que de la
bonne volonté
c'est même plus compliqué qu'un projet
d'ingénierie normal car il faut avoir
une vision globale de son produit il
faut pouvoir analyser tout son cycle de
vie
pouvoir comprendre comment est-ce qu'on
peut changer la conception la production
la distribution inventer de nouveaux
modèles
c'est par exemple comprendre comment
quand on développe un produit en open
source
on a des risques vis-à-vis de brevets
mais que de l'autre côté on peut se
créer une communauté qui va être fidèle
à son produit ou se dire comment quand
on va concevoir un produit de façon
modulaire il sera du coup plus
facilement recyclables
une fois en fin de vie c'est une
nouvelle façon de réfléchir ces
nouvelles façons de concevoir des
produits
on doit les apprendre alors vous en
apprendra une partie en école
d'ingénieur mais il faut être plus
curieux que ça il faut être curieux
s'informer se former
aller à l'extérieur parce que finalement
ce n'est pas que sont les bancs de
l'école que vous apprendre que vous
allez apprendre
et le troisième point pour faire de
l'ingénierie positive bah il faut qu'il
y ait des gens qui fassent de
l'ingénierie positive qui arrive à
passer à l'action
faut déjà qu'on encourage ces personnes
à pouvoir passer à l'action
et pour cela il ya un ingrédient un
élément qui est indispensable c'est la
collaboration
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours cette
image de l'industrie qui est très
compétitive on doit breveté ses
solutions
vous imaginez dans mon ancien poste en
un an j'avais déjà deux brevets à mon
nom mais en fait quand j'ai quitté mon
job
j'ai commencé à traîner dans des lieux
comme des faibles d incubateur d
entreprises de l'économie sociale
solidaire et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que c'était un monde qui était
bienveillant
on ne parlait pas que rentabilité mais
aussi d'impact et dans les entreprises
aussi on ça commence à changer on va
parler d'open innovation d'innovation
ouverte
c'est à dire qu'on fait sortir la r&d
des entreprises pour que start up écoles
labo citoyens et entreprises travaillent
ensemble et finalement on ne voit même
plus parler d'entreprise on va parler de
communauté on va parler de tribus c'est
à dire des groupes dits novateur qui
partagent les mêmes valeurs et qui
veulent concevoir des produits qui vont
dans le bon sens et ça nous pouvons tous
en faire partie alors je vous invite à
saisir cette opportunité d'entrer dans
l'ingénierie positive la technologie
n'est pas bonne ou mauvaise la
technologie c'est ce que nous voulons en
faire alors quand vous penserez à
l'ingénierie positif ne vous dites pas
que c'est quelque chose de naïf dites
vous que c'est notre opportunité de
réenchanter l'industrie merci
[Applaudissements]